2009 Hemi diagram we've got a couple of
these from the Amazon they're wicked
cheap cheap a fraction of the cost of
the dealer like a hundred and some
dollars fraction of the cost cheaper
what I want to do first and foremost is
we're gonna see if they work so we're
gonna use our Alltel TPMS tool just to
make sure the batteries are in these
little guys let's see from the button I
have my words that button works that bug
words suite have four buttons on now
that one sounds like a long cracker one
advantage of this TS 508 you can do a
remote key test just to make sure it's
putting out something I've logged in
here I got to boot it up did a system
scan to see what modules it's equipped
with we're gonna pop into the wireless
control mod and that will go hop in the
car hopefully this doesn't do anything
silly to it like you know completely
lock me out I think special function
it's been a long time since I don't I
don't do a ton of keys I'll be honest
with you to keep those these things all
the time
so we're gonna go into the wireless
control module let's see so we have
programming mission keys or key fobs
that's what we want to do stay exercise
caution
okay and I believe we're going to need
the pin number which I've already
obtained assuming I have the right one
I'm just kind of free handing you guys
here so oh I'll try to hold steady I'm
only one cup of coffee in so I shouldn't
have too bad to the jitters just baby
got a hundred 9k evidently they only
have one key for this and you got to
fiddle with it to make it start and
sometimes it just starts locking and
unlocking on its own okay so we got to
put in a pin 1 1 2 4
hopefully that's right okay let's see if
you think pin is centered three times
it'll go into anti-scam lock out holy
smokes we don't want that place an
unproven key into the ignition turn the
key that one and press one position and
continue so we're gonna shut this off
take that one out this is one of our
unprogrammed keys hey at least it's cut
right authenticating entering entered
pin programming keeps these wait
[Music]
program your key fob ik was successful
warning after all the keys are
programmed you must run PETM replaced it
in the PDM to transfer new program key
information from WC MTP failure to run
PE every place will cause improper
keyless go functionality continue to
program another key cycle ignition key -
prior to starting the vehicle
ok
pe M don't forget that folks and you get
the other a programmed key stick that in
[Music]
must run PE and replaced ok
all right that's the only keys ahead let
me shut this off looks like for this PE
M so I did what any good guy will do I
called Keith and so it's one the
thunders this never ran across tit he
says not all Chrysler's have the PM rfh
module question me whether or not the
vehicle had remote start which it does
any question whether or not it worked so
these are the other key fobs the new
ones it won't we could use this one and
see if the remote start works and it
does so that's good and then we just
fill it stick it in turn it on security
lights on
as great lights out
so that 5ik works we'll grab this one
[Music]
that one works
and we saved hundreds of dollars just
like Geico so there's that now he can
throw this one in the trash now if you
buy these you do have to cut your keys
let me uh let me set you down this is
weird
oh yeah and the console so if you buy
these you do have to take your key out
which is in here this is your mechanical
key slide that out you do have to take
and get this cut I can just go to the
hardware store and have a match to you
know your existing key I already asked
the customer about this they said none
of the door locks works so don't worry
about that because that's the only thing
you would use that emergency key for
both so make sure you've already checked
the other button all right fantastic
alright folks well I'll put a link to
the 431 pad here I think that's what
this one is the X 431 5 I'll put that on
there I'll put a link to those key fobs
I bought them dirt cheap and they work
you